hello everyone I didn't even realize but
today my channel hit 5000 subscribers
and I thought I'd commemorate this well
milestone by showing you a very nice
game played between mistletoe and none
other than Anatoly Karpov
this game was played in in 1987 the year
I was born and that's the four years
before tells death and it's the Blitz
game played in Brussels because how is
white and anatoly karpov is black so
this is a two years after Anatoly Karpov
lost his championship title to Garry
Kasparov top top lady for Karpov goes c6
and rc4 d5e takes d5 ctv v ctv v that's
the kind of variation of the car okay
Knight to f6 Knight to c3 Knight
captures on d5 Knight to f3 Knight to c3
V takes c3 g6 d4 Bishop to g7 Bishop to
d3
Karpov Castle tall castle Knight to c6
rook to e1 rook to e8 Bishop to g5 and
well this bishop here Bishop g5 mode
this is a very annoying move for black
he's eyeing this e 7 pawn and black
should either move his queen out of the
pin by maybe playing Queen d6 or maybe
playing h6 and kicking the bishop out
but former world champion anatoly karpov
decided to play Bishop to e6 and this is
a deadly there to give a guy like top
and I'm sure you don't think I have to
guess stalls next move in here top plays
rook takes on e6 of course and F takes
96 Bishop to c4 pinning the king queen
plays at the d6 defending the point
Queen to e2 piling on top that ecigs
pawn nice to d8 protecting rook to e1
and I'll work the c8 attacking the
bishop on c4 top plays Knight to D to
protecting the bishop King to h8 moving
the King out of the pin style plays
Knight to e4
attacking the Queen Queen to c7
attacking the bishop Bishop to b3 and
now II five and here since towel doesn't
have any more pieces to put into the
attack
so pushes his H bond so point to H for
the carpet place
he takes b4 which is all very good and
Todd pushes forward upon 2 H 5 and well
here
Karpov counter blunders he should have
played Queen to b6 protecting the g6
square but Carper captured G takes on h5
and humic Alto plays Queen takes on h5
which seems like the best move but it's
not in here actually found missed the
tactic as crazy as that sounds in here
tom is this nice f6 move because you see
the knight can be captured because the
rook is pinned from the Queen and if
Karpov doesn't want to lose this route
he has to play something like rotated
and now my stakes and h7 comes and this
is winning for white so I don't know
well this was a blitz game so it's not
that hard to believe that tom is
detecting but okay so top lace Queen to
h5 and carpel goes rook to f8 we have
bishop the c2 Queen to e5 and here tau
makes another beautiful move nice to g3
sacrificing a whole row Connie one
Karpov captures Queen captures and E 1
and out king page 2 and this is bliss
they're both in time travel and the
Karpov is actually better here well
which correct place would be a drawn
game stall is threatening checkmate h7
and here carpel blunders the game
what Karpov played h6 here but what if
what he missed was a bishop to h6 and
now it all has to give that a couple has
to give the bishop and after the bishop
is taken play rook to f7 and now h7 is
protected and this is OK for black but
Karpov missed this
after King 2h to come from plays h6 and
unfortunately it's all over for black
tile captured [ __ ] takes 986 King to g8
Bishop captures on g7 her updates on s2
of course the bishop cannot be taken if
King captures and this is well checkmate
so Karpov captures rook takes a knife to
Queen to h7 check into s7 Queen to g7 g
6 check King to g8 and Bishop to h6
check and carpel resigns after King to
HEV this is checkmate so this is a very
nice game uplift game between mix hotel
and Anatoly Karpov
to former world champions and yeah thank
you all for watching my videos thank you
all for commenting and I was thinking of
doing a livestream with a chess quiz so
it would be the concept would be like
maybe 30 or 40 questions and the person
who answers first the different who
collects the most points would be the
winner of the quiz and if you will be
awarded I thought maybe a chess set and
chess pieces so I'd like to I'd like to
hear your opinion would you be
interested in participating in an event
like this so yeah this is the game I
hope you enjoyed it and see you soon